[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome into your fantasy fire drill
everyone i
am matt camp and it is week number two
that's right your fantasy fire drill
brought to you
by the miller lite canteena were you
watching that to watch the games last
week you should be watching it this week
now we'll get to plenty of your
questions always hit those up in the brf
i'll get you covered there
but we have to talk about the injuries
heading into week number two a lot of
big names are already out this week
let's jump into it right now and we got
to start in tampa bay
with chris godwin chris scotland is out
he has the concussion so
mike edward mike evans gets the bump
he's wide receiver 12 and scottie miller
is my sleeper of the week he is a solid
flex play this week let's move on from
chris godwin
and go to aj brown because aj brown is
also out this week
another big injury it's a knee injury
taking out the top receiver for the
tennessee titans
uh corey davis is a fine flex play but i
like johnny smith i think he could be
the leading receiver
for the titans this week let's move on
from aj brown
to george kittle now we kind of knew
this might be coming by the way when you
hear players talk positively oh i'm fine
he's clearly not now brandon nyuk will
play today i'm not interested in him or
sunu
uh really i think it's all about the
backfield today so you're firing up
rahim moser and i do like jared mckinnon
as a flex play let's move on from
another wide receiver out is
kenny galladay he remains out with his
hamstring injury they're hopeful he can
be back
for next week marvin jones wide receiver
26 and once again i think tj hawkinson
can be a top 10 tight end we move on
from kenny gallaudet to
jamison crowder had a big week last week
but he will be out for the jets today
really don't have much interest in new
york jets although i will say that chris
herndod is a cheap dfs play could get a
lot of targets today
not a bad reach if you need him at the
tight end position
uh let's move on to denver now we have
some bad news and good news the bad news
is
phillip lindsey he is out today could be
two to four weeks so it's melvin
gordon's show
and he could solidify himself on the top
of that depth chart
melvin gordon to me is a solid rb2 but
we will see cortland sutton play this
week he is officially
active today for the denver broncos now
he's a low end wide receiver too to me
not an easy matchup against the
pittsburgh steelers but
certainly some help for their offense as
a whole didn't have him couldn't do the
jumping jacks or whatever on monday
night
he will play against the steelers today
let's move on though to
now some players who are in today
devonta parker is active today so good
news there for the miami dolphins
he's a fine wide receiver too i'd
probably rather have him
as a wide receiver of three so he's in
who else is in
in the one o'clock early games for you
today it's golden tate now golden tate
not a lot of interest to me
i still think darius slayton is the top
wide receiver for the new york giants
he's a solid wide receiver three uh
tate's fine
um schnelly shepard's fine these are
flex plays at best though for me but
tate will be back in action today
for the new york giants let's move on
from that to brandon cooks as we get to
our late game action
don't know if he's going to be out there
i would stay away i have will fuller at
wide receiver 21
i think he'd just stay away from cooks
if he's able to play
later on today now tonight's game two
big injuries
probably not that big but they're listed
because bill belichick doesn't like to
help us out
julian edelman questionable to knee
injury he's expected to play a fine wide
receiver three
and nikhil harry also should be out
there
banged up as well but this is what
belichick does he puts everybody in the
injured port they're all questionable
uh i'm not really into too much in the
keel harry unless you're really
desperate though
that brings us to monday night and
monday night we know it's a big one at
least the saints full of sins already
michael thomas is out for monday night
now if you have michael thomas i'm gonna
tell you right now
i'm taking this as a positive you don't
want him to play through these injuries
and battle through it and then there's
something that lingers all season it
could do that anyway
so michael thomas you already know is
out i like emmanuel sanders as a very
nice wide receiver too jared cook gets a
bump as well
and henry ruggs is expected to be out
there tomorrow night for the raiders
not somebody i'm looking to get into my
lineup but this gives you a reason if
you have anybody else to play in the
spot that doesn't play tomorrow night
you just get them out of your lineup now
those are the injuries
that we know about those are your
inactives for the one o'clock games
so now let's get into your questions i
know you have plenty of them i just
updated my rankings so let's help you
guys out right now
is this finally the corey davis breakout
year that we've been waiting for uh no
to me it's not i think this is today
obviously an opportunity for corey davis
but i still think it's all about aj
brown
derek henry and john smith let's go on
to the next one here
uh which rookie jumped out to you the
most in week one i mean it's got to be
clyde edward solaire and by the way
the ceiling is even higher for the chief
rookie running back because
he can still catch the ball he'll get
his carries into the goal line he is
clearly someone you should feel good
about if you took him in the first round
uh after that one we go to what's going
on in miami's backfield i don't see
gaskins being the guy
i agree look it's a bad team a bad team
using three different running backs
breida
and howard against i mean why would you
want to go after that this could be an
ugly rotation
on a bad team not a team i'm looking to
invest in when it comes
to miami dolphins backfield are you
dropping carry on johnson
i don't really see a need for him i like
swift peterson appears to be their guy
right now
carry on johnson he seems like the odd
man out i don't think he's worth keeping
around
another backfield with a lot of things
going on very much in flux right now so
no
not worth keeping carry on johnson
you're streaming qb's against the
vikings a winning strategy now i know i
gave you phillip rivers
i'm not as high on that as i once was um
but no i think it's one week i don't
think we overrate this
a lot of overreaction week one i see
more questions coming
our way that are going to be about
overreaction i don't think i am in on
that yet
uh where does scottie miller fall in
your wide receiver rankings he's wide
receiver 36 with the arrow pointing up
and half point ppr and i would say he
probably gets a little bit more of a
bump in full ppr
as i said chris scott went out with the
concussion today scotty miller and tom
brady
already look to have a connection
michael gallup or russell gage in a half
point ppr
i'll go with gallop i'm totally fine
with it i think the cowboys offense will
look better than it did last week
um gage is fine but i think gage got
more out of garbage time last week i
don't think that'll be a consistent
performance
from russell gage with le'veon help
her as the michael p ryan a good rv
stash no back to the dolphins
conversation
the jets stink i don't want jets if i
can avoid it i'll take chris herndon
crowder if he gets back healthy fine but
not really that interested
le'veon bell obviously when he gets back
as well but no i'm not trying to stash
away running backs on a bad football
team
moving on here uh can i start carson
wentz or gardner mitchu i have wence a
couple of spots higher than minshu
mitchu did a really nice job last week
did his best russell wilson performance
with the touchdowns and the completion
percentage but i do
think that he'll have a tougher time
against the tennessee titans
uh wence was fine not great last week
but good enough let's hope he doesn't
get sacked as many times
by aaron donald moving on from that
quarterback conversation to
what are your thoughts on the buffalo
backfield i have singletary but i am
scared to start him
and i understand that because of the
presence of zack moss um i think
singletary could have been a really good
rb2 and they have moss in the mix he's
probably more of a low end rb2 i
understand the pause
that you have uh cunningham about devin
singletary right now
uh let's see how much does a bump does
emmanuel sanders get with michael thomas
entry manual sanders to me
is a very nice wide receiver too wide
receiver 24 for me this week
i like jared cook and i like emmanuel
sanders getting the biggest bumps
for the saints in the absence of michael
thomas
uh is it too early a boyer to for dj
more owners to start panicking yes
absolutely it is it's one week there is
so much overreaction after one week
this past monday overreaction monday it
always
happens every single year guys will get
off to great starts that you never heard
of before
guys will get off the bad starts that
you drafted to be foundation players
do not freak out after one week of
football if there are no
injuries involved let's move on from
that one fair i get it but don't worry
about it too much
aside from cam are there any other
patriots you'd feel good about
starting from dynasty sags ah good about
not really probably edelman is fine and
ppr is a wide receiver three
it seems like sony michelle is the guy
but they split it up with burkhead and
michelle
uh no and james white as well so it's
cam it's edelman and then i think we
kind of see from there at least as it
stands
right now see what they do against the
seahawks tonight full point ppr
uh from j money will fuller stefan diggs
i have fuller a couple spots higher
not surprised at all to see him light it
up last week i think he could do it
again this week
cooks obviously even if he plays less
than a hundred percent i'm happy with
what's going on
in the bill's offense but it's one week
i will overreact to that you're going
with will fuller
in week number two uh james
which backup would you rather start
derek mckinnon or chase edmonds i just
said it before
with george kittle out today i know
ayoke is back i know they've signed
muhammad sunu
i'm not very interested in the 49er
passing game but i am
interested in their backfield we like
raheem moser we know that at great rb2
i do think mckinnon has some flex value
especially in ppr leagues because
he can catch the football uh let's see
edo should i start nahim hines or mark
ingram with standard scoring
great that you led with standard scoring
there because that is a clear difference
between these two players
i will go with mark ingram no i'm not
freaking out about last week
they blew out the browns why would you
overwork your veteran running back in a
blowout i liked what i saw
uh from jk dobbs moving on from that one
is jordan reed a sneaky tight end option
against the jets from niner nation very
very sneaky
uh i might go logan thomas of washington
first because he's got arizona and when
in doubt you start your tight ends
against arizona uh jordan reid a little
further down the line
maybe a cheap dfs play i could see that
happening today with north george kittle
uh moving on from that one uh ricky ppr
should i give antonio gifts another shot
or go with moss i like gibson i think
they're gonna go with gibson they pretty
much said that last week
is he ever going to light it up does he
have a high ceiling no but i do think
he's the guy in that backfield and as we
talked about buffalo earlier you got
moss he got singletary that could get a
little bit more annoying so stick
with antonio gibson uh is this year
calvin ridley eclipses julio jones
atlanta's top wide receiver
probably not but i do think this year
more than ever
it's probably going to be a 1-1 a
situation i don't think there's that big
gap
there used to be julio is still on top
of his game if
he remains healthy but i do think ridley
has gotten closer to julio great to have
them both
i think they can stain both of those
guys as top 15 wide receivers
uh moving on which qibi impressed you
the most weak one i think gardner
minshew did a heck of a job
i thought he looked really really good
dare i say baker mayfield look good on
thursday night as well
uh maybe aaron rodgers maybe we all
underrated aaron rodgers maybe that's
the one i should be talking about
because he played lights out maybe a
little mad they took a quarterback in
the first round so
all those names are brought up i'm gonna
say aaron rodgers impressed me the most
in week number one uh moving on from
that is paris campbell the top pass
catcher in indy
and should i flex him over tyler lockett
is he the top pass catcher
probably not but i think he's neck and
neck with t.y hilton no jack doyle today
but no you should definitely not play
him over tyler lockett like him tonight
against the new england patriots always
play lock it very simple i'm never
sitting that guy down
i took michael thomas miles sanders and
kenny galladay hook him
with my first three picks should i quit
fantasy forever hey miles sanders is
active today you're gonna be fine
uh you had a bad run there uh no you
should not quit fantasy forever you
should go to the waiver wire speaking of
which
watch waiver wire weekly every tuesday
i'll get you replacement names if you
need them for a week or five weeks we
got you covered there
what's the deal with leonard fournette's
low usage it was week one
he had only just joined the buck in the
years i'm not surprised at all
we'll go work him in slowly maybe they'd
speed that process up after they lost to
the saints last week
but it was one week he hadn't been with
the team that long he will eclipse
ronald jones we could take that to the
bank uh what storyline are you playing
the closest attention to
in week number two i really want to see
what the rams backfield looks like
are they going to stick with malcolm
brown or acres or henderson
i'd love that to solidify also can the
eagles protect
carson wenz today against aaron donald
and the rams this is a big game for
eagles by the way
jalen hurts is active today and if they
took him in the second round
they should put him on the field get
your quarterbacks moving away from that
pass rush it didn't work last week
the eagles should do that today should i
start robbie anderson or darius slate
i've anderson a couple of spots higher
clearly came through in a big way last
week i like darius slayton
anderson's a higher ceiling guy i think
slayton's a safer play
if you make that call based on what your
matchup looks like this week
i have james connor but missed out on
benny snell in waivers
should i over paint a tray for him no
you shouldn't and this is another big
story line i didn't mention this here
who's gonna be the guy connor's active
he's gonna play today
but with benny snell looking good last
week i think the steelers really have to
assess what they have in this backfield
unfortunately it could be a headache for
a couple of weeks
depending on what happens with james
connor today coming back from his injury
uh are you buying the sami watkins type
no it was week one
sammy watkins likes week one i need him
to like week two and three and four
and five and six and like week 14 when
people actually want to play him and
feel confident about playing him i need
to see sami watkins
put a string of good games together
before i will buy anything
when it comes to sammy watkins uh is it
fair to blame cooper cubs week one
fantasy dud
on his number change bring back 18.
supreme lenny i agree with you why would
he change something that was working so
well for him
and i'm sure there's an attachment to 10
or something like that but no
uh i'm not gonna blame a number change
but he should change it back i mean
that's a fair question
uh next up here battle of the browns
should i flex
hollywood brown or malcolm ground half
point ppo i'm gonna tell you to play
hollywood round i got him in a bunch of
leagues
i love him i think he's going to hit big
plays and continue to hit big plays i
know that can get a little dicey
tough to be consistent there but in that
ravens offense when he's making those
big plays
i will buy him all day long you're going
to play him over malcolm brown today
moving on from that melvin gordon ronald
jones at a half point ppr
i gotta go gordon by a little bit he's a
better back i know ronald jones is the
guy i know he's got carolina it's a
great matchup this is one of the few
weeks i'll feel okay about playing
ronald jones
but no phillip lindsey today i think
melvin gordon
puts a stranglehold locks down that top
spot
amongst the denver running backs and
they'll do it today against the steelers
uh who would you trade would you say
chris carson or he mostly for josh
jacobs now on paper that might seem like
a good deal
but i hate trading depth this early in
the season you know running backs are
going to get hurt you have a couple of
really good ones there and carson and
raheem moser
i'd rather hang on to those guys prepare
for injuries that are going to come
instead of making a big train now that's
a trade you make later on in the season
not in week number two are you fading dk
metcalf this week
with stefan gilmore covering him it's
not necessarily going to be the case
all game long good players go both ways
in dfs maybe i can understand that but
no
i am making sure he's in my lineup
because much like
stefan gilmore dk metcalf is a great
player in a great offense
and russell wilson is gonna cook so let
him cook with one of his sous chefs
dk metcalf next up here deshaun watson
against baltimore
ryan tannehill against jacksonville uh
once again
a good match tough matchup but a good
player so i'm playing deshawn watson i
draft him to be my qb one
i'm putting them in my lineup regardless
of the match up your lower expectations
a little bit that's fine
but you stick with your guy and you're
sticking with desean watson today
against the baltimore ravens by the way
tan hells and have aj brown so that
makes it even easier uh should i start
christian kirk or deontay johnson i like
deonte johnson i would fire him up today
uh it's a good matchup for him i liked
what i saw from a week one
i think christian kirk is going to get a
little bit lost here and there now that
deandre hopkins
is with the arizona cardinals so deante
johnson is in your lineup today
uh grand lazar to valdosta scantling who
do i start i said this last
tuesday when we talked about waiver wire
weekly lizard is the safer play i think
he's the more consistent plays the ppr
play
if you're a big underdog you think needs
some big plays today by the way
lions are down their top corner valdez
scantling is the higher upside play
there you go uh who do you have ranked
higher for the rest of the season keenan
allen or cortland sutton
i trust allen a little bit more just
because i think he's a better player
pretty closer i think sutton's got a
higher upside with drew locke but there
are a lot of malice to feed in both
spots allen is a little bit of a safer
player
but they're pretty much neck and neck
solid wide receiver twos
for both players there from the afc west
kenyon drake or chris carson in a half
point ppr
pretty close one to me i feel better
about carson tonight
against the seattle seahawks assuming
against new england patriots
catching the football is a great bonus
for chris carson
arizona getting chase edmonds involved
gives me a little bit
of pause when it comes to ken drake so
i'm back on chris carson for this week
uh i'm desperate at tight end gronker
goddard desperate you got dallas got her
dallas goddard is my number seven tight
end this week i wish i could be
desperate enough to use a number seven
tight end
that's right erz and goddard both in my
top seven tight ends because they're the
best two receivers
on the philadelphia eagles you're
playing dallas goddard and now with
desperation
with confidence you're playing him hot
hot spike uh what week one breakout
performance
was fool's gold it's always sammy
watkins it was like devry henderson back
in the day with the saint it's always
sammy watkins i'm sticking with that
he needs to string a bunch of good games
together before i will believe
in sammy watkins being a reliable part
of my fantasy team
uh is the ages wonder adrian peterson
the backbone of detroit
creative i think he is i could change my
mind next week
but i feel like mature fish patricia got
him on that team
late in the preseason for a reason he
was the guy last week i think he'll be
continue to be the guy for the
lions although i don't have a lot of
faith in his upside this year
uh let's see 16 team ppr should i start
traequan smith or john brown john brown
is getting completely overlooked had a
great game last week
16 team ppr would be happy to get in my
lineup trey quan smith has a dark throw
with michael thomas out get john brown
in your lineup and then a 16 teamer
a really good wide receiver to him and
josh allen continued that connection
from last year uh one of the chances
chubb and hunt both finish the year
as rb2s are better great i told you this
kareem hunt's gonna be in rb2 all season
long
i got nick chopping my lineup i sweat it
out like everybody else does when kareem
hunt gets on the field
but those guys should be leading the way
in that offense i think both guys will
finish
inside the top 20. it happened a couple
years ago with devonta freeman and tammy
coleman in atlanta and it could happen
again this year with those two running
backs
in cleveland what else do we have keep
them coming
uh joe mixon the most overrated fantasy
running back league he played two games
last year he was outstanding on an awful
awful bengals team so don't overrate
don't freak out about two games i
like what joe burrows doing he'll have
some growing pains
don't you dare call joe mixon overrated
he's a really good player
all right let's get a couple more in
here did you like what you saw out of uh
libiscus chanel last week yes i
did now is he going to be on top of that
depth chart is he going to be the go-to
guy for garner mitchu i can't say that
because chark's there i know d.d
westbrook's inactive again today
um i like what i saw could he emerge as
the second option or not in that offense
yes it is extremely viable if that
happens so i like what i saw let's get
one more in here
does clyde edward solaire goal line
struggles
limit his ceiling his one week of goal
line struggles is one week where he lit
up the texans and had a massive fantasy
output
they're not struggles it was one week
he's gonna catch more balls
he's gonna be just fine i can't believe
we're talking about a rookie running
back you drafted in the first round
and his struggles when he put up like 25
fantasy points last week
stop overreacting to one game and enjoy
the fact
that you have a rookie running back
leading the way in the best offense in
football hopefully i have led you
to a very good lineup this week because
i got you covered and by the way
as you know your fantasy fire drill is
brought to you
by the miller like antenna and you can
visit millerlitecantana.com and check
out the new music video
oh yeah it's a trip go check it out it
features the cantenna
i'll be back with you on tuesday for
waiver wire weekly and of course on
thursday we'll get your story lines and
injuries updated it's all covered hit
that brf
get your questions in and go in in week
number two
i'm matt camp this has been your fantasy
fire drill presented
by the miller like antenna see you on
tuesday
[Music]
foreign